welcome back to the Drew Barrymore show
I'm your host slash referee Brandon
Marshall we have
we have two amazing teams creating the
ultimate reading Nook in our design duel
it's Drew and Ben versus Rawson Aaron
and their husband and wife okay and this
is a thing happening right now all right
so let's check in on how they're doing
Drew yeah this is better see what I'm
saying this is what I was saying the
magic how are you doing how are you
incorporating our mystery items
um well good okay uh are you panicking
yeah
no we're not panicking where are the
mystery items okay we have our cookies
there's the mystery right there okay you
did it and here's
them right there whoa look at this
come on more more
what we like doing a reading no because
there you go you sit when you're done
and just read I'm reading about art but
hey Ross Ross Ross yes oh one mistake
can anybody find a mistake here can you
find it what is it what is it the
wallpaper's upside down Rob
no I'm I'm gonna have to minus two
points dare you notice that we have 60
seconds left team you guys can do it
Choice 60 seconds left listen I'm the
referee we have 60 seconds
is there anything we can do just last
minute two no you guys are done read
okay this is this is what it's about I'm
going to have to deduct you two points
though I feel pretty good out of here
all right how do you guys feel about
Drew and Ben
see
you see the magic you see what I'm
saying look what they're doing
more is more oh that looks good Drew I'm
just there we go no that's oh that's
better okay we have 30 seconds left
they're still working do you guys feel
comfortable I think you guys may need to
add one or two things because they're
they're really stepping it up with them
they're stepping up you have so much
here we have we have 10 seconds left 10
seconds yeah 10 seconds left what do we
do what do we do what do we do what do
we do you all ready
[Applause]
I can't count
okay Drew bin yeah
stop stop stop Drew no do you want to
talk yes uh tell me about your reading
Nook uh and how you guys came through in
a clutch
well we went with a very avant-garde
design plan typical design okay let's go
over to Aaron and Ross now Aaron and
Ross um hi hi we're feeling good yeah
you guys shocked me yeah I was working
this side of the room and then I came
back and you guys were just chilling and
it was like amazing yeah great job well
you know when you find when you find the
right one you stop looking when you're
done you're done you know what I mean
we're smarter not harder when it's
perfect what do you do now we got to go
to the audience it's up to you guys all
right okay if you think Drew and Ben won
please make some noise
okay
okay okay go go go go go go go go go go
okay okay okay if you think Aaron and
Ross won scream
come on
hey you know what you know what it is
and I'm a referee and I gotta I gotta
stay down the middle I think we need to
change the name to the Ross Barrymore
show and maybe you'll get a little bit
more love yeah I will I don't know the
winner is Drew and Ben
[Applause]
you won I mean I have to say we talk a
lot of smack around here but when it's
deserved it's deserved well done really
you pulled it out that means your side
of the audience wins a prize oh does it
bookshop.org gift card to stock up for
your own reading
that's right just that side well I is it
just one side Drew come on if no one can
go home empty handed Drew come on I know
[Applause]
[Music]
winners and Brandon you're the best ref
ever doing the news doing cooking
segments you know how much I love doing
this show well time out time out I feel
like I need to be deducted points I
knocked over your face
yeah but thank you so much thank you
thank you but I almost broke everything
beards Hometown takeover Sundays at 8 pm
on HGTV because you know where I will be
on Sundays at 8pm watching this watching
them I mean I just love you guys so much
I love you
[Applause]
congratulations
I'd love to know because you really are
one of my favorite couples like I love
watching you I love how you work
together and you live together and you
have children together and you play
together is there any Napier wisdom that
you could drop for us it might just work
for you guys it's all individual and you
know couple based what works for one
doesn't work for another but what is the
Napier wisdom too it's very good we over
share with each other we tell each other
everything and people say that they say
like you know communication
communication is key you gotta tell each
other everything but it's I know it
sounds Elementary but it really is I
don't have misunderstandings because we
know everything we have all the
information that is available
[Applause]
[Music]
they are so good
I love you
[Music]
foreign